(crowds cheering)
- [Narrator] Soccer is the most
popular sport in the world.
And for soccer fans
there's a collectible item
that's taking their world by storm,
the Panini Soccer Sticker Album
that comes out every four years.
We'll let this guy explain how it works.
Because, well, he wrote an
entire book about stickers.
- My name is Greg Lansdowne,
and I'm the author of “Stuck on You,”
the story of football stickers.
(whistling and cheering)
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] OK, Greg, so,
what's this all about?
- Well it's a very simple concept.
You start off with the album.
And from there, you need to
collect packets of stickers.
For the World Cup, there's
five stickers in every packet.
In this particular World Cup album,
there's 682 spaces to fill.
And the idea, or the name of the game,
is to fill up the sticker album.
Once you start to getting
doubles of stickers
that's when the real fun element comes in
and you start swapping with people.
Panini's first album
Mexico '70 started off
with the album being distributed
in just a few European countries.
That's now grown and you
can get Panini Stickers
in over 100 countries worldwide,
and that's growing
every single tournament.
I'm sure they will leave no stone unturned
to make sure that you
get stickers in the hands
of everyone around the world, ultimately.
- [Narrator] Who is the
biggest collector in the world?
- Well there is a gentleman in Italy,
the home of Panini Stickers.
His name is Gianni Bellini,
and his sticker collection
needs to be seen to be believed.
- [Narrator] Introducing Gianni.
(speaking Italian)
- [Narrator] Gianni lives
in a small town in Italy,
which happens to be only 20
miles from the Panini factory.
(speaking Italian)
- [Narrator] So, there you have it;
if you didn't know about soccer stickers,
now you can kick your own
collection into high gear.